just landed
in belfast
awaiting the queen's arrival later on
today
and yeah it was in the last 20 minutes
that we were told by buckingham palace
that unfortunately the queen is now no
longer able to come and as you said
there in their statement they make it
very clear that
um she's taking this advice um from the
royal medical household they've said to
her that she has to rest for the next
few days um we're also being told though
that she is in uh good spirits but in
many ways it's probably
not surprising that they told her to
take a rest because the last couple of
weeks have been
incredibly busy when you consider that
she is 95 years old yes she has all of
the best possible help around her and
she lives a very privileged life but for
95 years old she has been undergoing a
very busy work schedule so just last
night we saw her
at the global investment summit
reception that was being hosted at
windsor castle actually she seemed in
fantastic spirits
i watched all of the pictures
of her meeting and greeting the various
business leaders that boris johnson
number 10 had wanted invited to wins the
castle and there was a wonderful moment
where she stopped and spoke to
john kerry and said oh i saw you on the
telly last week referring to the fact
that she'd seen john kerry had recorded
a video message for prince william's
earth shot prize um of course now that
she is older of course now that prince
philip is no longer by her side we are
now increasingly seeing other members of
the royal family around her so also last
night we saw
prince charles and
prince william but yeah last night's
engagements at windsor castle was just
one of i would say over half a dozen
engagements that she's done in the last
couple of weeks um she's returned from
from scotland where she spent her summer
holidays in balmoral um
of course up in scotland before she flew
back down
to england
she opened the scottish parliament gave
a speech there
she then traveled back down
to windsor we saw her hosting the
commonwealth baton relay on the
forecourt at buckingham palace and she
also last week i was there as well she
went to open
the welsh parliament and then yeah as i
said last night she also hosted that
global investment summit so at 95 years
old she certainly has not slowed down
and i think whenever you speak to the
palace they make the point that it's the
queen who who drives this this busy
schedule she's the one that has wanted
to get back out and about especially
when you consider that because of covid
for around 18 months
that schedule of royal engagements and
meeting and greeting all of that had to
come to a complete standstill a schedule
that she's been so used to carrying out
throughout her nearly 70 year reign she
was there at windsor castle within that
bubble being protected
from everybody because of covid and so i
think since all of the restrictions have
started to lift she has been desperate
with other men's royal family to get out
and about congratulate those who've gone
above and beyond when it comes to to
helping their communities when it comes
to covid but yeah i think of course
there will be understandably worry about
the queen and the fact that she is now
being told to rest up she is 95 years
old but i think just to reiterate the
palace is saying that
she has reluctantly accepted his medical
advice to rest for the next few days in
some ways maybe that ties in with the
fact that yesterday we also heard that
she'd turned down a prize of the aldi of
the year because she basically didn't
feel that she feels old enough for that
um we're also told that the queen is in
good spirits she is disappointed that
she's no longer able to travel to
northern ireland over the next couple of
days but also what we're being guided on
is that this is not covered related
and uh rhiannon as you say she's been
around the united kingdom recently in
scotland and in wales uh can you what
can you tell us about what she was due
to do in northern ireland
so we understand that this afternoon she
was due to visit uh hillsborough castle
hillsborough recently has been given the
honor of being renamed royal hilfr so
she was she was due to
to mark that and congratulate those
who've been part of
that important campaign to make that
happen and also as we saw in wales and
in scotland she was due to meet up with
some
covered heroes as i said it's been a
really important point for her that she
gets
gets around the country gets out and
about and sends other members of the
royal family out and about to
congratulate everyone who's really gone
above and beyond when it comes to
working um throughout the pandemic and
also there were reports that she was due
to attend a very important um
church ceremony which is due to take
place tomorrow um recognizing the
centenary um of northern ireland
the palace were not commenting uh on
that but because the president of
ireland michael d higgins
last month has said that he wouldn't be
attending
that service there has been a great deal
of chatter over here about whether or
not the queen would attend but yeah as
we now know uh under medical advice the
queen has been told that she cannot come
to northern ireland and yeah the doctors
around her clearly have said you've had
a busy couple of weeks and of course
don't forget really importantly in a
couple of weeks the queen is due to host
the opening reception for cop26 we have
heard so much to remember the royal
family
over the last couple of weeks
about climate change about our
environmental responsibilities and i
think they the palace and number 10 will
be desperate for her to be
at the start of cop26 the royal family
in a way the ultimate welcoming party
really helping to set that tone ahead of
some difficult discussions ahead up in
glasgow but certainly welcoming the
delegates
and makes them feel welcome here in the
uk